为什么大部分的散户没有一个比较理想的收益
甚至还在股市里面租套房
谈股色变苦不堪言
原来股票的账跌都是强装行为
解密强装密码才是散户获得收益的关键
大家好我是大鹏
大鹏带你重新认识股票投资
第一次听课的朋友可以关注我的频道
以便长期的在这里进行股票学习
今天我要为大家分享的是
强装套利模型之解密强装密码
学会强装套利模型
你也可以做到跟装套利
从此改变目前的投资败局
话不多说
让我们开始吧
在这个案例当中
我们可以看出
从这个位置开始股价的向上运行
是什么原因导致这只股票
从这个位置能够涨到这个位置呢
接下来是什么原因导致
股价从顶部开始一直下跌到这个位置呢
很多股民看到了这种股价的涨跌
不知道其原因
有些股民呢也会看成交量
那么成交量方面
到底给我们提示了哪些信息
首先我们来看一下比较明显的几个位置
在这个位置我们看到有一个放量
导致股价迅速的向上
后面成交量开始缩量
到后面这个位置开始成交量
再一次放量
有一句话是这样说的
不怕下跌
怕放量
所以这个顶部位置对应下方的成交量
进行了第一次的放量
经过两天又一次放出了一个大量
所以导致顶部的资金开始外流
到这个位置再一次放出大量
横盘震荡过后开始迅速的下跌
为什么呢
因为前面上涨的这个放量
被后面的几次流出的放量
已经消化殆尽了
后面的基本上是震荡下跌
震荡下跌
其实我们可以看出
在这个位置有一波反弹
在这个反弹过程当中
我们看到里面的量是多还是少呢
是非常少的
也是为了进一步出货
其实从这个图上
我们就可以看出内在的导致这只股票
在这个位置开始迅速的上涨
到顶部以后开始下跌
就是强装行为
那么很多股民的成交量也看不懂
所以呢在股市里面涨也不知道为什么会上涨跌也不知道为什么会下跌所以要么就是坐过山车要么就是租套房
今天呢我就通过一个模型
来帮助大家去解密
强装套利的密码
其实首先的出发点
就是强装的思维
我们散户能不能站在
庄家主力的角度
去思考问题
这样我们就不难理解
庄家的拉伸
庄家的洗盘
庄家的出货
等等一系列的操作
只有这样
我们才能够做到解密强装的密码
今天呢
我也为大家提供一种思路
首先我们要解密强装密码
按照扬名心学
就是心急理
什么叫心急理呢
首先我们要通过两个方面去做
第一个就是听其言
第二个就是观其形
怎么去听其言呢
要站在阻力的角度
去看一下阻力的生命线
尤其是中期生命线
到底它是怎么运行的
观其形呢
就是阻力的量能的变化
前面我跟大家已经讲过
关于阻力生命线的问题
今天呢
我站在阻力能量的角度
跟大家去分享一下
OPV这个指标
那么OPV指标呢
它的英文全称是Unbalanced Volume
它的华文名字呢
就是能量潮指标
能量潮指标呢
是将股市的成交量与股价的关系
数字化直观化
以股市的成交量变化
来衡量股市的推动力
从而研判股价的走势
下面这个图呢
就是OBB能量潮指标
这里面的黄色线为OBB的均线
白线为OBV线
接下来呢
我们就简单的介绍一下OBV指标的计算公式
分为三种情况
第一种
如果当天的收盘价比前一日的收盘价要高
那么OBV就等于前一天的OBV加上当天的成交量
第二种情况
如果当天的收盘价比前一日的收盘价要低
那么OBV就等于前一天的OBV减去当天的成交量
第三种情况
如果当天的收盘价与前一日的收盘价一样
那么OBV就等于前一天的OBV维持不变
这次简单的为大家去介绍了一下OBV能量潮指标的计算公式接下来呢我们就来看一下实际的应用刚才我讲到了要听其言观其行
听其言和观其行
到底如何进行解密
强装密码呢
我们同样还是看
刚才的这支股票案例
刚才我跟大家去讲过一种思路
就是心急理
听其言
那么这个白色的线呢
就是主力的中期升级线
股价开始在这个位置上穿主力的中期升级线
过后直线的拉伸
一直在白色的主力升级线的上方运行
而且远离白色的这个主力中期升级线
这就是说明主力在进行强势的拉伸
这就是强装行为
接下来慢慢的有远离
这个中期阻力生命线
开始慢慢靠近
到这个位置开始跌破
这就告诉我们
从这个位置过后
其实强装的能量开始衰减
为后面的下跌
做了前期的铺垫
如果我们看到这一点
就能够跟装在这个位置讨历
所以这就是听其言
我们用到了阻力的中期生命线
接下来我们要进行第二部分
关其形
我们用到了OBV能量潮指标
我们可以看到主力能量的变化
在这个位置
无论是从主力中期四面线也好
还是白色的OBV上穿黄色的OBV均线也好
基本上都可以看出
这就是强装拉伸的一个开始的位置
到这个位置我们看到
OBV白色的线
开始下穿黄色的OBV均线
以及蜡烛的收盘价
跌破阻力的中期升线
这样就可以断定
阻力在这个位置
开始进行第一次的套利
到后面这个位置
就开始彻底的套利出局
如果我们散户投资者
没有按照这样的方式去分析
那么很难在这个位置
跟装套利
也很难在这个位置进行落袋为安
所以这就是导致广大散户投资者
要么就是过三车的行情
要么就是住套房的原因
今天呢
我通过主力的中期生命线
以及OBV能量潮
就可以帮助大家
按照扬明心学心急理听其言观其行外在的形态加上内在的量能的验证这样就可以解密强装的密码
接下来关于强装套利模型之
解密强装密码
战法呢做一个总结
这里我们用到了扬名新学新吉理
第一个听其言收盘价
上穿主力中期声线
第二个关期型主力能量的变化
就是OPV能量桃指标
OPV白色的线上穿OPV黄色的均线
这就是强装拉伸的开始
相反的如果收盘价开始跌穿主力的中期生命线
以及OPV白色的线开始跌穿OPV黄色的均线
就是强装套力出局的位置
这样我们就可以根据这两个方面来做到解密强装密码
我们首先讲到了强装的思维
然后呢
讲到了跟装的行为
最后我们来解密强装密码
心急理
听其言
观其行
希望大家能够按照这样的强装泡立的模型
来去解密强装的密码
最后告诉大家一个好消息
针对强装泡立的模型
我们近期举办了一个强装套利的训练营
针对第一次接触我们的国民朋友
前100名即可免费报名参加
具体的时间是9月26号到9月30号
分为5讲
第一讲我们会讲到强装极致盈利模型
第二讲强装龙头个股模型
第三讲强装飞机跑道模型
第四讲强装短线暴力模型
第五讲强装飞龙在天模型
如果你想报名强装套利训练营的抓紧时间
拿出手机扫描屏幕中的耳码
名额有限抓紧时间报名吧
好了
以上就是今天为大家分享的强装套利模型之解密强装密码
如果你对刚才所讲的内容还有什么不明白的地方
欢迎在视频下方的评论区告诉我
如果你喜欢我的视频
欢迎大家订阅我的频道
记得点赞关注加收藏哦
我后期还会分享更多的实战干货
我们下一期的课程再见
股市有风险
投资需谨慎
上述观点仅供参考